♪
>>> YOU JUST TOPPED INTO THE NEW
SEASON OF GROUP CHAT LIVE IN THE
BLEACHER REPORT AT PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
I'M GREG IVORY ALONGSIDE THE
LOVELY ERIN DOLAN.
IT'S WEEK TWO OF THE NBA SEASON,
ERIN.
WHAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT LESSON
YOU'VE LEARNED SO FAR AFTER A
WEEK OF GAMES?
>> WHAT'S UP, GREG?
>> I WOULD SAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT LESSON IS IT IS WEEK
TWO.
DO NOT OVERREACT JUST YET.
ALSO, NOW THAT WE HAVE DATA AND
INFORMATION PROVIDED ON CERTAIN
PLAYER PROPS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, AND SEE HOW TEAMS PLAY
AGAINST THE SPREAD.
YOU CAN USE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE BETTER PICKS
AND BETTER BE ON THE FAN DUEL
SPORTS BOOK AND START PLACING
THOSE BETS.
>> PLACE THOSE BETS.
WE'RE GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND
WE'RE GIVING AWAY JERSEYS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE FIRST
ONE IS GOING OUT NOW.
IER IN,OU WANT TO GET IN THE
APP AND HOOK SOMEBODY UP WITH
THE HOODIE RIGHT NOW?
>> YES.
GREG'S ALLOWING ME TO USE THE
HANDY DANDY iPHONE.
HE USES THE iPAD.
I'M GOING TO GO INDERMAN.
I-N-D-E-R-M-A-N.
WE'LL SEND YOU A HOODIE.
>> SHOUT OUT TO INDERMAN, ERIN
IS HOOKING YOU UP WITH A HOODIE.
ERIN, I'M IN THE COMMENTS NOW
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
AND I SEE -- I SEE ERIN.
ARINGS22.
FANS ARE HERE KNOWING MPJ IS
GOING TO GO OFF TONIGHT.
I HAVE HEARD THAT MPJ IS GOING
TO GO OFF TONIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN DM'ING ME ON INSTAGRAM.
SHOUT OUT TO ARINGS22.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH $125
TO BUY WHATEVER JERSEY YOU WANT
TO.
ERIN, IT'S TNT TUESDAY.
MEANING FAN DUEL IS RUNNING OUR
FAVORITE BET.
THE 3X2.
THERE WILL BE FIRST THREE
POINTERS IN THE GAME AND WE
ASKED YOU ON TWITTER, WHICH 3X2
WILL CATCH TONIGHT AND WILL IT
BE THE SIXERS OR THE NUGGETS
TAKE IT ON THE JAZZ?
HERE ARE THE RESULTS, ERIN.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
THIS IS A CLOSE ONE.
YOUR SIXERS, TAKING ON THE
KNICKS AT 47% AND UTAH TAKING ON
DENVER SITTING AT 53%.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH 3 x 2
IS A LOCK TONIGHT.
LET'S GET CREATIVE AND I NEED
EMOJIS AND I NEED EVERYBODY
RIGHT NOW.
COMMENT, WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
I'LL GIVE OUT A HOODIE TO A
COMM
COMMENTER THAT I SEE.
RUN THOSE COMMENTS UP.
WHICH 3 x 2 DO YOU LIKE BETTER?
PHILLY, NEW YORK, DENVER, UTAH.
I HAVE TO GO WITH THAT AND LAST
GAME, SETH CURRY HAD
THREE-P
THREE-POINTERS IN THAT QUARTER
AND IT WAS NOT THE NEW YORK
KNICKS INSIDE MADISON SQUARE
GARDEN AND HE'S MADE THE MOST
THREE-POINTERS ON THEM AND I'M
GOING TO ROCK WITH THAT FIRST
GAME AND IT ALSO IS MY TEAM
WHICH DOES, INDEED, HELP, BUT
YOU'LL GO WITH THAT LATER GAME,
RIGHT?
>> I MIGHT GO WITH THAT LAKER
GAME, BUT YOU ALWAYS ACCUSE ME
OF BEING A HOMETOWN FAN, BUT I
KNOW YOU'RE PARTIAL TO THOSE
SIXERS, ERIN.
I KNOW YOU'RE PARTIAL TO THOSE
SIXERS.
LET ME HOP IN THE COMMENTS.
WHY NOT?
I'LL JUST HOP INTO THE COMMENTS
MTNUGSFAN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY TO A HOODIE.
STRIPED GIRAFFE, WINNERS ONLY,
AND THAT IS OKAY, WE ARE SHOWING
GOOD VIBES AND SHOUT OUT TO YOU,
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, I SEE THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING TODAY.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING TODAY.
DIF83 SAYS SIXERS VERSUS KNICKS.
HE'S RIDING WITH YOU.
I'LL JUST HOP IN HERE AND I'LL
GET MY TAKE AND I'M RIDING WITH
DENVER, UTAH, BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO GO WITH YOU, AND I WANT
TO GO ON THE OTHER SIDE AND I'LL
SEE WHAT THE COMMENTS ARE GOING
TO PICK AND THE NEXT COMMENTER
THAT I'LL SEE, WE'LL RIDE THAT
3 x 2 TOGETHER AS A FAMILY,
OKAY
OKAY, ERIN?
>> I'M GOING TO SCROLL.
JULIO HERNANDEZ.
HE GAVE US A GOOD TAKE.
HEY ERIN AND GREG, THE JAZZ AND
NUGGETS WILL HIT THE 3 x 2, SO
MANY ALL OVER THE FLOOR
ESPECIALLY WITH GOBERT, AND
SHOUT OUT TO JULIO HERNANDEZ FOR
THE TAKE AND THAT WAS A REALLY
GOOD TAKE AND HE EXPLAINED
EVERYTHING PERFECTLY FOR US.
SO WE ARE RIDING, ERIN, DENVER
VERSUS UTAH 3 x 2 AND SHOUT OUT
TO JULIO.
THAT WAS A GOOD TAKE AND LET'S
MOVE ON, ERIN.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP HOW MANY
POINTS WILL JOEL EMBIID SCORE
TONIGHT AGAINST THE KNICKS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
HOW MANY POINTS EMBIID IS
PUTTING UP AND WE'LL DM ONE
PERSON THAT GETS CLOSEST AND
HOOK YOU UP IN THE ERIN AND
EMBIID IS SITTING AT 26.5 POINTS
AND HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT
NUMBER?
>> SO YOU KNOW I LOVE THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ERS.
I'M A HUGE, HUGE FAN OF JOEL
EMBIID AND IT MAINS ME TO SAVE
26.5, AND HE'S ONLY POSTED 22,
19, 22 IN THE LAST THREE GAMES
AND THIS IS INSIDE MADISON
SQUARE GARDEN.
I WOULD TAKE THE OVER AND WHEN
YOU SEE MADISON SQUARE GARDEN
ROCKING IT'S HARD TO HAVE ONE
PLAYER TO HAVE A HUGE STANDOUT
PERFORMANCE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE
UNDER 26 1/2 FOR TONIGHT.
>> WOW!
I AM SURPRISED BY TH, ERIN.
I AM VERY, VERY SURPRISED.
I THOUGHT THAT YOU WOULD ROCK
WITH JOEL BEING THAT PHILLY IS
YOUR TEAM, BUT LET ME HOP INTO
THE COMMENTS AND SEE WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT K.A. WALSH SAYING 13 UNDER
FOR SURE AND SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE, AND 303, JOEL ENJOYS THE
GARDEN.
JOEL ENJOYS THE GARDEN.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, 303, 23 -- 22
GOLD AND EMBIID WITH 35 POINTS
AND I'M GOING TO STOP THERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO WITH 22, AND
I'LL GO WITH UNDER 261/2.
HE'S FIXING THAT KNICKS DEFENSE
AND THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING TOUGH
AND THIS GAME IS AT MADISON
SQUARE GARDEN.
IT IS NOT AT HOME AND I SEE
EMBIID WILL HAVE A TOUGH MATCHUP
TONIGHT AGAINST THOSE KNICKS AND
HE'S GOING TO GO UNDER THAT
POINT TOTAL.
>> REMEMBER WE --
>> I MEAN, YEAH, WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE.
LET'S GO.
REMEMBER, WE'RE GOING TO HIT YOU
GUYS UP AFTER THE GAME AND HOOK
YOU GUYS UP AFTER THE JERSEY,
BUT I HAVE MORE JERSEYS TO GIVE
AWAY RIGHT NOW SO LET'S ROLL TO
THIS NEXT SEGMENT.
ERIN, YOU ARE A PHILLY NEGATIVE
AND THE SIXERS ARE YOUR TEAM.
IT SEEMS A LOT OF MESSES GOING
ON RIGHT NOW IN PHILADELPHIA,
BUT THEY DO HAVE TWO WINS ON THE
BOARD AND ERIN, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE
ON ALL OF THIS BEN SIMMONS'
DRAMA.
I AM SO SICK AND TIRED OF
HEARING ABOUT THE DRAMA.
I'VE HAD PEOPLE DM ME FROM THE
PARKING LOT WITH PINATAS WITH
HIS FACE ON IT AND BETWEEN THE
ONE GAME AT HOME, BEN SIMMONS IS
STILL MY BROTHER AND THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE PRESS
CONFERENCES THAT HE'S DONE.
IT'S AFFECTING THE TEAM.
I'M SICK ASK TIRED OF IT,
BECAUSE IT IS ALSO IMPACTING THE
ODDS.
>> IT IS IMPACTING THE ODDS AND
IT'S IMPACTING THE TEENS ON THE
FLOOR AND IMPACTING THE BETTER
MARKET,IER IRN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
PHILLY ODDS.
THERE IT IS.
IS THERE ANYTHING HERE YOU WOULD
BET, ERIN?
>> ONE THING I WANTED TO KNOW,
TO WIN THE NBA CHAMPIONSHIP 20
TO 1, THAT HAS NOT MOVED
WHATSOEVER AND BEHIND THE NETS
WHO ARE AT MINUS 260, AND I
THINK OF ALL OF THESE MARKETS
AND IT'S STILL 14 TO 1 AND HE'S
ABLE TO PUT A TON, AND LAST
SEASON NICOLE YOKICH WAS A LONG
SHOT BEFORE THE SEASON AND THE
GOOD MAN COULD WIN IT AND IF YOU
SPRIRNGEL SOMEONE ON EMBIID TO
HAVE A BETTER PRICE, 14 TO 1.
DO I LIKE THAT BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THAT THAT IS ON THE BOARD THERE.
>> WE DO KNOW JOEL EMBIID IS THE
IN PHILADELPHIA.
IF HE IS IN THE MVP RACE AND
LET'S PULL THOSE ODDS UP.
YOU GUYS HAVE THE MINUS 2200 TO
MAKE THE PLAYOFFS?
>> I THINK THAT THAT IS A LOCK.
I THINK THE PHILADELPHIA 76ERS
WILL MAKE THE PLAYOFFS, BUT I'M
NOT MATERIELING YOU TO BET WIN
DIVISION PLUS 250.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ERS AND THEY HAVE
WON GAMES WITHOUT BEN SIMMONS.
I DO THINK THAT THEY CAN PULL
THAT OFF AND WIN THE DIVISION AT
PLUS 350 IF I HAD TO TAKE A BET
HERE AND LET ME HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS AND GIVE AWAY SOME
HOODIES.
I'VE GOT JACOB PASTOR, BEN
SIMMONS IS A PROBLEM IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
A TRADE SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
ERIN, I KNOW YOU LIKE THAT TAKE.
>> WHAT IS HE GOING TO GET RIGHT
NOW IN.
>> IT'S TOUGH.
I WOULD LOVE TO GET BRADLEY
BEALE.
BEN'S SHOOTING HIMSELF IN THE
FOOT EVEN FOR A TRADE AND NOBODY
WANTS TO DEAL WITH HIM.
>> MY GUY, DEKE GEEK IS IN THE
COMMENTS AND SIMMONS IS GOOD AND
NOT GREAT.
THE DRAMA IS MAKING THEM WORSE
THAN SIMMONS' PLAYING WILL MAKE
THEM BETTER.
NONE OF THOSE BETS ARE WORTH
TAKING AND WINNERS ARE PLEASE,
AND I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN GET
YOU A JERSEY AND I CAN GET YOU
PROBABLY YOUR TENTH HOODIE.
SO SHOUT OUT TO YOU FOR YOUR
TAKE.
ERIN, THE SIXERS ARE YOUR TEAM
AND I'LL LET YOU PICK A
MMENTER TO WIN A HOODIE AND
GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND GIVE A
LUCKY FAN A HOODIE.
>> OKAY.
WHO WILL WE GIVE IT TO?
TOO MUCH DRAMA.
THEY NEED TO REPLACE HIM.
I AGREE WITH YOU, FOR THAT
REASON YOU'RE GETTING A HOODIE.
CONGRATS.
>> SHOUT OUT, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> ERIN, AS YOU KNOW, LAST WEEK
I WENT TO THE LAKERS-WARRIORS
GAME WITH MY MAN METTA WORLD
PEACE, AND WATCHED THE WARRIORS
WIN.
THEN WE ALL SAW THIS MESS HAPPEN
IN THE SUNS GAME WITH THE
LAKERS.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> ANTHONY GOES OVER TO DWIGHT.
>> A.D. WAS REALLY UPSET THERE.
>> WHEN YOU'RE ON A TEAM LIKE
THAT, LIKE I MENTIONED LITTLE
TIFFS.
>> AFTER THAT, ERIN, AFTER THAT
MAGIC JOHNSON DROPPED THIS TWEET
RIGHT HERE.
CHECK THIS ONE OUT.
HE SAID THE LAKERS HAVE A TEAM
AND BASKETBALL ISSUE.
I NEED YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF YOU
THINK THE LAKERS ARE GOING TO
RECOVER?
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
ARE THE LAKERS DOOMED?
THEY HAVE ONE WIN AGAINST
MEMPHIS, BUT IT'S NOT LOOKING
TOO GOOD IN L.A.
>> THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A HEATED
EXCHANGE.
I THINK WE ALSO PUT SO MUCH HYPE
INTO THIS TEAM COMING INTO THE
PRESEASON WHICH IS WHY IT'S
MAKING IT EVEN WORSE AND THEY
KNOW WHAT TYPE OF PRESSURE THEY
ARE UNDER, AS WELL AND NOT
SAYING THEY'RE LOOK AT THE FAN
DUEL SPORTS AND THE ODDS AND ON
PAPER THEY'RE SO GOOD, THEY CAN
HAVE A TON OF STARS ON THE TEAM,
BUT REALLY DO YOU HAVE THAT
CHEMISTRY?
THAT SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING ON
THE COURT ESPECIALLY WHEN
TEAMMATES TAKE YOU ON THE LOCKER
ROOM, BUT TO PUBLICLY KIND OF DO
THAT KNOWING THE CAMERAS ARE ON
YOU AND THEN TO LOSE THE GAME IS
KIND OF UNFORTUNATE.
I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO BALANCE
BACK AND THE ODDSMAKERS ARE
STILL AGREEING AND THAT'S GOING
TO BE A CONTENDER IN THE NBA
SEASON.
>> IT'S ONLY TWO WEEKS UNTIL THE
NBA SEASON.
THE TEAM FULL OF HALL OF FAMERS,
YOU MIGHT HAVE A TEAM FULL OF
EGOS.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
L.A.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
LAKER ODDS.
THEY ARE STILL FAVORITES TO WIN
THE WEST AND SECOND FAVORITES TO
WIN THE FINALS.
DO YOU STILL THINK THOSE ARE
GOOD BETS AFTER WHAT WE'VE SEEN
SO FAR?
ANY MARKETS YOU LIKE HERE,IER
SN
ERIN?
TO WIN THE DIVISION PLUS 155 IS
SOMETHING YOU WOULD WANT TO LOOK
AT AND LeBRON WINNING MVP WOULD
NOT BE HIS YEAR, PER SE AND
OVERALL THE LAKERS, 0 AND 3
AGAINST THE SPREAD IT WOULD BE
HARD TO GIVE A TAKE ON THESE
SIGNS AND YOU WOULD MONITOR THE
SIGNS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS WITH THEM.
>> ERIN, I'LL BE FRANK.
I'LL BE HONEST.
IF WE CAN PULL THAT GRAPHIC BACK
UP ONE TIME BECAUSE I JUST WANT
TO WALK THROUGH IT.
I JUST WANT TO WALK THROUGH IT
AND JUST BE BLUNT WITH YOU GUYS.
THEY'RE NOT WINNING THE FINALS
BECAUSE -- YEAH.
THEY'RE NOT WINNINGE THE FINALS
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WIN THE
WEST AND I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'LL
WIN THE DIVISION AND NOT GOING
TO TOUCH AND THAT RIGHT THERE
CATCHES MY ATTENTION AND SITTING
AT 1500, I WILL SPRINKLE
SOMETHING ON THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LeBRON
JAMES, THE GOAT, SITTING AT PLUS
1500.
I'LL SPRINKLE SOMETHING ON THAT
SO THAT WILL BE MY TAKE ON THOSE
LAKER ODDS, BUT LET ME HOP INTO
THE COMMENTS, ERIN.
I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY AND A
HOODIE THIS TIME.
I'VE GOT INDERMAN BACK WITH
STEPH AND DRAYMOND AND SHOTS OUT
TO YOU INDERMAN, ROCK IT WITH
THE WARRIORS AND I SEE ERIC
REINHART SAID THE LAKERS WILL
CATCH ON FARTHER INTO THE SEASON
AND THEY NEED TO BUILD CHEMISTRY
AND IT WILL HAPPEN THIRD SEAT IN
THE WEST.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, ERIC.
THAT DESERVES A JERSEY AND ERIC
REINHART, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
I'VE GOT TO GIVE AWAY A HOODIE
RIGHT HERE, ERIN.
A LOT OF TAKES IN THE COMMENTS.
THESE GUYS ARE PROS AND IN
LeBRON WE TRUST.
77 YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, LET'S TALK ABOUT ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR AND LET'S KEEP THIS
GOING AND TALK ABOUT WILL ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR AND JAYLEN GREEN
AGAINST THE CELTICS SETTING THE
ROCKETS' FRANCHISE RECORD FOR
THREE POINTERS BY A ROOKY AND HE
TIED THE NBA RECORD FOR MOST BY
A TEENAGER IN THE SINGLE GAME.
SHARING THE RECORD WITH ANTHONY
EDWARDS.
HE ALSO MADE THIS CRAZY DUNK.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> HE GETS THE OUTLET PASS.
>> RIGHT OVER JASON TATUM IN THE
PHILADELPHIA 76ERS JERSEY.
WE DIDN'T TAKE HIM.
A CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER TIME.
>> THE SIXERS MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN SMART TAKING JASON TATUM,
BUT TATUM WAS SMART IN THAT
PARTICULAR PLAY BY NOT JUMPING.
HE STAYED ON HIS FEET, BUT GREEN
REMAINS THE FAVORITE TO WIN
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND GET IN
THE COMMENTS IF YOU THINK IT'S
TOO EARLY TO SAY GREEN IS A
LOCK.
WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE PICK TO WIN
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT REEK OF
THE YEAR.
>> JAYLEN GREEN.
HE'S AVERAGING 16 POINTS, FOUR
REBOUNDS AND THREE ASSISTS SO
FAR DESPITE THE ROCKETS BEING 1
AND 2, AND SOME OF THESE OTHER
PLAYERS COULD POTENTIALLY BEAT A
JAYLEN GREEN AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE STILL LONG SHOTS AND IT
IS WEEK TWO.
HEALTH AND AVAILABILITY IS STILL
A HUGE THING, SO I'M NOT
SURPRISED THAT JAYLEN GREEN HAS
MOVED DOWN THAT FAR, BUT I DO
THINK ODDSMAKERS WILL CONTINUE
TO MOVE THIS MARKET A LOT OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
>> YOU MENTIONED LONG SHOTS,
ERIN.
AND DEAVION MITCHELL AND I'LL
STAY ON THE DEVION MITCHELL FOR
A REASON FOR HIS DEFENSE AND
PRESENCE THAT HE HAS ON THE
FLOOR.
HE GOT OFF TO A ROCKY START
SHOOTING IN THE NBA, ERIN, BUT
HIS LAST START AGAINST THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
HE PUT UP 22 POINTS ON 9 OF 16.
>> HE'S JUST SHAKEN.
-- EXACTLY.
SHAKING OFF THE NERVES.
I DO THINK THE GAME WILL BEGIN
TO SLOW DOWN FOR HIM AND THE
OFFENSIVE NUMBERS WILL KEEP
GOING UP AND UP AND UP.
SO I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH MY GUY
DEVION MITCHELL, BUT I AM BACK
INTO THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES AND I WANT TO MENTION,
I'M NOT GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO
PEOPLE REPEATING THE SAME
COMMENT AND I'M LOOKING FOR NEW
TAKES, INTERESTING TAKES AND
GOOD TAKES.
I'VE GOTTEN GO GARDEN SAYS
JAYLEN WILL WIN, ERIN.
HE SAYS JAYLEN WILL WIN ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR.
I SEE ANOTHER ONE, CHRIS DUARTE.
K-I-R-Y HAWKINS.
CHRIS DUARTE IS A SLEEPER FOR
SURE.
IER IRN, TALK TO ME.
HE IS A SLEEPER.
HAVE YOU SEEN HIM EARLY ON IN
THE SEASON IN HE'S BEEN BALLING.
>> YEAH.
THE TOUGH PART ABOUT WATCHING
SOME OF THE REEKS OOKIES ALSO T
AREN'T ON GREAT TEAMS AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE CAVS AND THE
PISTONS AND LIKE I MENTIONED,
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO CHANGE.
WE SAW SO MUCH CHANGE FROM LAST
WEEK.
>> THAT IS A FACT.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYONE THAT I
MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO SEE GQUINN24 SAYS GREEN
HAS
HAS THE NICEST SHOT OUT OF ALL
OF THE ROOKIES.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL WALKING AWAY
WITH HOODIES.
LET'S TALK MVP AND I WANT
EVERYONE TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME YOUR EARLY FAVORITE.
ERIN, DO YOU HAVE AN EARLY
FAVORITE?
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS FOR MVP.
>> LET'S PULL THESE UP.
LAST WEEK I'D SAID DAMIAN WILL
ASHGS
WILLARD 18 TO 1.
HE'S SANDWICHED WITH YANIS.
LUCA
LUCA DONCIC WHO WAS AT PLUS 500
AND JOEL EMBIID AND YOKICH WHO
WON 18 TO 1.
I DON'T THINK HE WILL REPEAT,
BUT I WILL STICK WITH DAMIAN
WILLARD BECAUSE A SHEERT WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THIS AND THEY WILL
SCORE AN AVERAGE OVER 30 POINTS
AND I JUST THINK THE GAME OUT OF
SOME OF THE PLAYERS ON THE BOARD
AND SOME OF THE PLAYERS WHO DO
AND DON'T PLAY BACK-TO-BACKS, HE
WILL REMAIN RELATIVELY HEALTHY
FROM THE THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE REGULAR SEASON
AND I'LL STICK WITH MY GUT ON
THAT ONE, BUT I'D LOVE TO HEAR
YOUR TAKE, GREG.
>> DAME WAS MY MVP PICK LAST
YEAR AND YOU KNOW, HE JUST GOT
BETTER THIS YEAR.
SO I DO LOVE THE PICK AT PLUS
1800, BUT ERIN, THERE'S THIS MAN
BY THE NAME OF WARDELL CURRY AND
LAST WEEK HE WAS PLUS 800 AND
NOW HE'S PLUS 600 AND THE
ODDSMAKERS ARE CATCHING ON SO
LISTEN TO ME, EVERYBODY, GO PUT
THE BET IN NOW.
GO PUT ITN NOW AND IT WAS PLUS
600 AND IT'S GOING TO KEEP GOING
DOWN BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO KEEP
BEING PHENOMENAL AND THE
WARRIORS ARE BETTER THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR, I THINK THAT STEPH
CURRY, THIS YEAR WOULD BE A
BETTER TEAM AND THAT WOULD ADD
TO THE POTENTIAL OF STEPH CURRY
WINNING MVP.
>> NO BIAS.
NO BIAS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS GIVING AWAY
HOODIES TO SOME TAKES.
NICK'S PICKS 13 SAYS STEPH WILL
BE A MENACE TO THE LEAGUE THIS
YEAR.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU NICK'S PICKS.
I DO AGREE.
STEPH WILL BE A PROBLEM.
CDUB75 SAYS JOEL WILL HAVE TO DO
A LOT TO WIN MVP THIS YEAR,
ERIN.
I DO AGREE, HE WILL HAVE TO DO A
LOT AND SHOUT OUT, AND ERIN, I
HAVE ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY.
SO IT'S TIME FOR OUR LAST
SEGMENT, ERIN.
THIS WEEK AND FOR THE REST OF
THE SEASON WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
VERY, VERY SPECIAL.
I'M BUILDING MY SAME GAME
PARLAYS, AS USUAL, BUT NOW YOU
ARE GOING HAVE A CHANCE TO RIDE
WITH ME.
I NEED ALL OF YOU, AND I MEAN
ALL OF YOU TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF MY PARLAY, WHICH LEGS IS
RUINING THE PARLAY AND I'M GOING
TO NEED YOU TO GRADE MY PARLAY
FROM AN A TO AN F.
I'M GIVING OUT A JERSEY TO MY
FAVORITE TAKE.
ARE YOU GUYS, READY?
>> YEAH.
LET'S GET TO IT.
LET'S GO.
DONOVAN MITCHELL.
DONOVAN MITCHELL, THE STAR OF
UTAH, THE STAR OF THIS JAZZ TEAM
GO SCORE 29 POINTS, DONOVAN.
I NEED SOMETHING FROM YOU
TONIGHT.
ERIN, TS IS DOABLE, RIGHT?
THIS IS DOABLE.
AND THIS WILL BE SUCH A
COMPETITIVE GAME THAT SOME OF
THESE PLAYERS WILL STAND OUT.
GOOD VIBES.
LOVING THE VIBES THERE TO START
THIS OFF.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON.
MIKE CONLEY, THE POINT GUARD OUT
THERE IN UTAH, ERIN, HE LIKES
THE DISH THE ROCK, WE'LL GO
SIX-PLUS ASSISTS FOR MY GUY MIKE
CONLEY.
SHOW ME THE LOVE.
HE'S AVERAGING FOUR.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
HE'S AVERAGING FOUR IN THE
SEASON.
THAT'S BAD VIBE, THOUGH.
NO, YOU WANT ME TO HIT AND I'M
ONBOARD.
GO TO THE NEXT ONE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH ME.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND THOSE BAD
VIBES INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AND
JUST SEND THEM ON.
>> I WANT THEM FOR EVERYBODY'S
SAKE.
GOOD VIBES.
I LIKE THE VIBES THERE, ERIN.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE JOKER.
THE JOKER, TEN-PLUS REBOUNDS AND
GO GET TEN.
IER IN, ERIN, I'LL JUST GO INTO
TEN REBOUNDS.
LOVE THAT.
YEAH.
>> LOVE THAT.
THANK YOU.
LOVE THE GOOD VIBES.
I WAS JUST GOING TO MENTION.
I WAS GOING TO MENTION THAT I
THINK THAT HE'S GOING TO GET A
TRIPLE DOUBLE AND THAT WOULD
LEAD ME INTO MY NEXT TAKE AND
WE'LL GET INTO THE SIX-PLUS
ASSISTS TONIGHT.
GIVE ME SOME LOVE.
ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF HE
DID HAVE A TRIPLE DOUBLE.
HE'S BEEN CARRYING THE TEAM FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF GAMES, MAKES
SENSE.
MVP FOR A REASON.
IT LOOKED LOOK A GOOD PARLAY.
LET'S SEE THE ODDS.
PULL THE ODDS UP SO YOU CAN SHOW
THE PEOPLE.
-- YOU JUST WANT TO SEE ONE GO,
AND WE'LL SEE ONE GO THROUGH THE
NET, THEN WE CAN START PLAYING
AROUND A LITTLE BIT AND ERIN,
BEFORE I GET INTO THE COMMENTS,
WHAT ARE YOU GRADING MY PARLAY?
>> SO I'M GOING TO GRADE THIS
BETWEEN A B AND A B MINUS AND
I'LL BUMP IT UP TO A B.
I ASK MY TEACHERS TO BUMP ME UP,
AND WE GOT THOSE TO GO WITH THE
LONG SHOTS AND SOME THAT YOU
THINK ARE GOING TO HIT AND
GETTING THE PLUS MONEY.
I'M ALL FOR IT.
YOU DID WELL.
>> ERIN GAVE ME A B.
I'LL TAKE THAT B IS FOR SURE --
THAT'S A 3.0.
SO -- YEAH.
I'LL DEFINITELY TAKE THAT UP.
>> YOU'RE ABOVE THAT.
>> Bs DEFINITELY GET THOSE
DEGREES.
>> LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING OUT A JERSEY AND I'M
GIVING OUT HOODIES.
HERE WE GO.
WE SEE CONNELLY NO BUENO.
WOW!
THAT IS BAD VIBES.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU HAVE A HOODIE ALREADY.
HERE WE GO.
THE BIG PERM.
THE BIG PERM SAYS B-PLUS,
NUGGETS PLAYING A BACK-TO-BACK,
BUT BOUNCING MAY REJUVENATE
THEM.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE B-PLUS, NICK
PERM.
HERE WE GO.
REYES SAYS B-PLUS AND CONLEY CAN
BE A HIT OR MISS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, THOSE TWO
DESERVE HOODIES.
>> IT'S WORRISOME.
♪
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY, ERIN?
>> ONLY THEY WERE WORRISOME.
A-MINUS, GREAT ONE.
>> HERE WE GO.
WE HAVE KING OF SPORTS 21 AND
THIS IS FOR THE JERSEY.
HE SAYS MITCHELL WILL BALL.
25 SHOULD BE A CAKE WALK.
CONLEY AVERAGES FOUR TO FIVE
STEALS EASY WITH FOUR ASSISTS
AND TEN ASSISTS ARE EASY AND
WHICH SHOULD HIT.
GOOD LUCK, G-MONEY.
APPRECIATE YOU KING OF SPORTS.
YOU SAID MY ODDS AREN'T JUICY,
BUT I'M SENDING GOOD VIBES YOUR
WAY AND HOPEFULLY JUICE UP YOUR
DAY BY SENDING YOU A JERS OF
YOUR CHOICE.
YOU WANT TO HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS AND GIVE AWAY A HOODIE?
>> LET'S DO IT.
ONE LAST HOODIE, GUYS.
HOP IN.
SOMEBODY DROP ME A GIPHY.
>> THE HOODIES.
>> BRGROVE2.
BRBRO2 AND THE SHOW.
>> A SHOUT OUT TO BRBRO FOR
DROPPING THE GIF.
THAT IS WHAT ERIN WANTED.
SHE WANTED THE GIF AND THEY
DROPPED IT.
THAT'S IT, ERIN.
IT'S TIME TO SIGN OFF.
THANK FOR TAPPING INTO THE GROUP
CHAT PRESENTED BY FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU HEARD TODAY.
THE DENVER UTAH 3 x 2 IS A LOCK.
JOEL EMBIID IS A LOT, AND PHILLY
IS IN TROUBLE AND THERE MIGHT BE
VALUE TO WIN MVP FUTURE.
DON'T OVERREACT TO THE LAKERS'
PROBLEMS.
THEY'VE STILL GOT HALL OF FAMERS
AND GET ON FAN DUEL TO TELL MY
PARLAY AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
HERE GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES,
MORE JERSEYS AND MORE LOCKS IF
YOU WON A HOODIE TODAY, BRBET,
NOT GREG, NOT ERIN, BUT
BRBETTING WILL DM YOU, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT?
ERIN, I WANT YOU TO GIVE OUT ONE
MORE HOODIE JUST FOR THE FUN OF
IT.
WHY NOT?
>> JUST HOP IN THERE AND --
FIRST ONE YOU SEE.
>> WAIT, DID YOU GIVE ONE OUT TO
DEKE GEEK YET?
>> HE HAS, LIKE, 20 OF THEM.
OKAY.
HE HAS, LIKE, 20 HOODIES.
SAY IT ONE MORE TIME?
>> JACOB PASTOR 13.
>> JACOB PASTOR.
JACOB PASTOR 13 OPINION JACOB
PASTOR 13 WITH A HOODIE AND
SHOUT OUT TO THE GIF RIGHT HERE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
GET ON FAN DUEL, RIDE WITH US
AND FOLLOW US ON SOCIAL
ALONGSIDE THE LOVELY ERIN DOLAN
I'M GREG IVY AND WE ARE LEAVING
THE GROUP CHAT.
>> SEE YA.
♪